it's okay breathe we're gonna get
out of this and we're gonna go home
nice that isn't what you think
it's a cage
but we can help each other
he's that monster you cannot
trust him I'm just a man
you thought you could win I don't
have to win we both just have to lose
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. Marvel dropped
a brand new Ant-Man of the Wasp quantumania
trailer video with a bunch of new footage so we'll
break it down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're
also doing a giveaway for IMAX tickets because
tickets are on sale now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and post all your Kang
theories in the comments below it does seem like
this Kang might wind up being the one that they
face or one of the many that they face during
Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty because I do think that
we're going to see a bunch of versions of Kang a
bunch of Kang variants in Avengers 5. reportedly
we're also going to see a bunch of Kang variants
during Loki season 2 because the Kang Multiverse
War 2.0 will still be playing out but a lot of
what's happening in Ant-Man the Wasp Quantumania
in Kang's master plan is related to that the Kang
Multiverse war and if you think I'm evil just wait
till you meet bye variance during a couple new
interviews that Michelle Pfeiffer did for Janet
Van Dyne and during the new trailer there's all
these references to this dark past that Janet
Van Dyne had when she was stuck in the quantum
realm for 20 plus years everybody wondering why
she didn't tell everybody else about Kang when
she escaped the quantum realm and part of it has
to do with her guilt over what she did during
those 20 plus years the way she talks about it
she talks about this relationship that she used to
have became very interesting type of relationship
not in the traditional sense like not like going
out with someone or like having an actual physical
relationship with someone when she talks about
this dark history of Janet Van Dyne look how
she changed fundamentally as a character when
she was stuck in the quantum realm the things
she's probably guilty about that she didn't want
to talk about with the others when she escaped
like Hank Pym for one is because she's guilty
over having helped Kang start to achieve his
goal of winning the kang Multiverse War so when
she's telling Scott Lang he's a monster you can't
trust anything that he says what she's probably
talking about is that she at some point met Kang
when she was stuck in the quantum realm and
he was in the middle of using the quantum
realm Quantum energy to win the Kang Multiverse
War because the quantum almost sort of like the
blood vessels of the entire Multiverse of all of
reality it's kind of like a train depot to all of
time and space like all points and all timelines
in every universe so it sounds like Kang wants to
use it to basically destroy all the other Kang
variants timelines and make his Supreme and at
some point when Janet Van Dyne was stuck early on
when she was much younger she met him and he lied
to her about what he was doing and she helped him
complete his plan so a lot of what he's like a lot
of his technology in his grand plan for destroying
all of reality technically was made possible by
Janet Van Dyne but also when he's talking to Scott
Lang about how this place isn't what you realize
it's a cage he's been trapped there and that's
why he's captured them because Janet Van Dyne also
found out about what he's doing and Stranded him
there by stealing some of his time chair devices
there's this device that you see on his time chair
that's glowing you see him putting something into
it later like some energy this seems like it's
going to activate her or fix whatever Janet Van
Dyne did to break it so that he couldn't use it
in Escape so it just sounds like Janet Van Dyne
is like slowly revealing this to Hope and Hank
in everyone else like oh by the way yeah this
guy he's really terrible I kind of accidentally
wound up helping him start to complete this plan
to destroy all of reality so please don't be mad
at me like she's begging Scott Lang not to give
in to what kang is telling him he can do I could
give you anything you want I'll give you literally
more time with Cassie because he was stuck in the
quantum realm for five years of her growing up is
basically another version of the same bargain
that he who remains in Miss minutes gave to
Loki and Sylvie in the Loki finale how would
you like to win you want The Infinity Gauntlet
yours how would you like to wake up tomorrow with
just a lifetime of happy memories because the
whole idea is that Loki is basically getting it
on here he's in love with the variant of himself
which is exactly something you would expect from
Loki like he's a pure narcissist of course he
would fall in love with himself but part of the
idea is that Kang tries to win over Scott Lang by
offering him more time and then just flips to full
out villainy like look if you don't help me I will
destroy your entire reality everything that's ever
existed it'll be as if there was never an Ant-Man
which is more of a surgical strike on his personal
timeline rather than just destroying an entire
timeline like having Elias eat an entire timeline
an entire alternate universe that was kind of
what he who remains Kang was offering Loki and
Sylvie a surgical strike on their timeline like
a surgical construction of this Franken timeline
where they could live together and it wouldn't be
weird like Odin wouldn't be upset at what Loki was
doing they even referenced the infinity gauntled
do you want to live in a reality where you won
during the first Avengers movie where you have
The Infinity Gauntlet where Sylvia is your wife
and nobody thinks that it's weird Kenya's Master
time travel technology hyper Tech future Tech so
much that he can do stuff like that without it
completely breaking all of reality they got into
the concept of fixed points in time during the
what if series like certain important points in
the timeline that couldn't change otherwise all
of reality would just completely break down which
is what happens during the doctor strange episode
but it sounds like Kang a thousand plus years in
the future has figured out how to get around stuff
like that that's how powerful he is I've already
talked about the different types of quantum energy
too the connections is a Fantastic Four because
they have the same types of blue energy the same
types of portals like you see him standing
on one here using the energy this way that
Mr Fantastic uses is his portal to get around
in the a38 universe Kang is the descendant of
Mr Fantastic's family that they're very very
distantly related also the writer of Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness said that they based
his Quantum energy portals on Doctor Doom's time
travel platform which is another connection
to Kang in the comics who based his initial
time travel to his time chair here that he's
sitting in on Dr Doom's time travel platform
he dug Dr Doom's plans out of mothballs and
just made them better with his Hypertech a
lot of you've also asked about the celestials the
eternals Easter eggs that are all over his rings
of power here and his time travel chair there are
all these Advanced symbols that look just like the
celestial symbols in the eternals movie that are
written all over the celestials that you see in
their energy when they teleport themselves around
I think what they're trying to imply here is that
Kang is using Celestial technology in some of
his Hypertech which makes sense like Celestial
Technology Way way more advanced than anything
that anybody has access to at least in present
day in the trailer Kang tells Ant-Man I Know How
It Ends like he's talking about knowing the end
of the timeline because he's gone all over the
timeline so he literally knows everything that's
going to happen that's what he who remains Kang
told the Loki and Sylvie I know everything that's
going to happen at least up to a certain point
naturally Kang probably had a certain level of
technology and then used it to travel into the
future and get more advanced techno technology
and then integrated into his technology in the
past take the best technology that you can find
from across the timeline from the most powerful
beings and then incorporate it into his current
technology here that you see him with that's
really why he's so dangerous is because he has
unfettered access to the most advanced technology
from the future meaning that he's so much more
powerful theoretically than any of the characters
from the present which is another reference to a
funny moment that they have together when Ant-Man
is meeting him for the first time so there's like
a longer version of the scene where he's like wait
a minute who are you you better watch out I'm an
Avenger and Kang is kind of bemused by like
oh you're an Avenger have I killed you before
because the whole idea is that when he's speaking
to him in the quantum realm here even though he's
been trapped for a long time he's survives
a much bigger version of the Kang Multiverse
War up to this point that's what all the scars on
his face his body are probably from he's probably
survived battles with many other variants of the
Avengers and survived them meaning that they were
unsuccessful in stopping him and he's killed a
bunch of them in the process the whole idea of
Multiverse Avengers will also get get into that
during Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty and Avengers 6
Secret Wars but mostly Secret Wars there's a
couple other new characters that they tease
during some of these new footage and previews that
they've released William Jackson Harper is playing
a telepath character called Kaz a lot of people
initially thought that that was just meant to be
code for Quasar because of the quantum bands of
Quasar you talk about Quantum energy and you talk
about Miss Marvel's Bengals people are like wait
a minute are those like the quantum bands there
might be some Easter eggs that they weave in later
in the comics but he's not meant to be Quasar or
anything like that he's just a completely brand
new character that's original to the movie that
they created for the movie itself during the
movie there's meant to be this metaphorical
Grassroots resistance against Kang inside the
quantum city that you see like there's a giant
war that he's looking out out over his Fortress
a bunch of the regular inhabitants there just
hate what he's doing under trying to oppose him
they wind up running into them here like you see
them standing wondering who all these people are
some of them are humanoid and some of them are
completely non-human it also seems like this final
battle that they have where you see this wreckage
all around him and he's blasting Scott Lang
with his blue Quantum energy next dim you can
actually see the ruins of his time chair here
it sounds like their final battle is going to
be in his Fortress here and Ant-Man will wind up
stopping him from destroying all other timelines
like he'll destroy his larger device and stop
that but Kang will wind up escaping in his time
chair so that he can go on to the events of
Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty in the background but
if there's any other footage or Easter eggs that
you spotted in the trailer footage that I didn't
talk about in the video just write down below in
the comments this is just the beginning the movie
is going to be coming out in a couple weeks so of
course there's going to be a bunch more trailers
and footage they release I just did a brand new
Mandalorian season 3 trailer video you can click
here to watch that and click here for my Last of
Us episode 2 trailer video with even more Pedro
Pascal thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!